I'm an actor okay you know have you
traveled at all yeah I've been to 14
countries in Europe Africa most states
in the US you must train and work out
every day am i oh come on yeah
hi I'm Liz I'm 20 years old
my name is 74 and I'm gonna be
interviewing these three men to figure
out which one is secretly a millionaire
I think I'll be looking for you know
like fake confidence
who's your interest definitely like how
educated they are hopefully I'll be able
to figure the right one out so what do
you like to do I'm an athlete I do
Ironman for like long-distance
triathlons so I just try to do that for
fun oh that's cool you must train and
work out every day yeah pretty much take
a little bit of a break during the
offseason but pretty much train every
day where is your last one it was in
Mont Tremblant Quebec Canada employment
wise what kind of work do you do um I'm
really focused on triathlon at this
point it's kind of my main job right now
oh really
yeah it's quite a busy schedule to train
so that means you don't really have any
business experience or anything like
that
am i okay do you like to do anything
else uh-huh have this little drum that I
like to play this every once in a while
are you married I'm not married it's
geared do you like to go out uh not
really
I'm an early sleeper yeah like to get in
bed by like 8 or 9 o'clock
do you yeah early to them I try to I try
to sleep when the Sun Goes Down
when the Sun comes up just try to be in
sync with I guess whatever's happening
with the earth have you ever been on a
cruise or anything like that cruise I
have I have been on a cruise yes I have
okay what do you like to do in the
morning I think the first thing I like
to do is to drink a big glass of water
and just get out in the Sun a little bit
it's kind of my big thing just see the
Sun and be happy that I made it to the
next day yeah okay ask what's up with
the hat from Colorado Cortez Colorado
and now you're in California no no no my
daughter have a daughter that goes to
Azusa Pacific and I have another
daughter or their husband are they do
music stuff like that yeah what'd you do
Iowa I'm kind of retired right now you
know my wife and I had my wife there's a
lot of nonprofit stuff so you think you
retired so I was in the construction
industry so what what are your interests
I mean you know any hobbies or you know
we're retired now so so we you know the
cortes it's a small town so I do a lot
of fishing and we do some hunting you
know that's the only sport that you do
at golf once in awhile but I'm not that
good I don't keep score but my brother
he's he's it like a Utah State coach
champion kind of thing so I go with him
and he and he keeps going yeah yes I
just go mess around but I golf yeah have
you traveled at all yeah I've been to
most states in the US 14 countries into
Europe Africa South America Central
America India Asia China Hong Hong Kong
a few places okay so you've probably
been on cruises and stuff I want to but
my wife is not big on water at all she
says you can go but you gotta go by
yourself so well come on yeah the 3-day
to Mexico that's you'll do that one
either so yeah that's on the books right
yeah that's my life sounds boring right
to Kelvin oh you know I know how this
yeah of course your rivers a big
and I'm on fire are you from from
Suffolk in England just outside London
what brings you to the u.s. I'm an actor
what kind viateur film TV Oh everything
yeah what was your most recent project
it's good school Julius Caesar the Opera
oh yeah yeah I sing as well so I was in
a small-scale prep like not-for-profit I
don't know anything about a private
neither did I feel about a year ago so
you travel very much so I'm trying to
try to get out and see the country thank
us for Big Sur yeah that's the country
well it does it like yeah I like
traveling cause you can see very
different from England I'm sure he looks
more space did you graduate from college
or anything I went to drama school I'm
and I'm an actor so in in England so you
you've just gone forward otherwise I did
one year at university I was doing
science and then I didn't complete that
and then I went to drama school after
that so I kind of in that time I was
doing lots of drama anyways and I
realized to make the wrong decision to
do science so then I went to do drama
okay
never been on a cruise never been on a
cruise they think he look like the
cruise in time
you never know yes cruising times I
think I have enough information how
these three my conversation with them
been interesting
the gentleman from law from Colorado he
said he was in the construction work and
he might have owned a construction
company s well took that into
consideration I think it's the guy with
the cowboy hat I think that the
millionaire is just
oh I got the sake of
[Laughter]
[Music]